I know myself that the more I study
Islam the more I look at the evidences
improves makes me a better human being
helps me to be more merciful and loving
because this is what islam teaches to be
loving and kind with all of mankind so
now when you get to know islam you truly
get to know it yes there are atrocities
that are committed and we condemn me
things on both sides but we as muslims
need to be at a higher level at a higher
standard as the Creator tells us in the
verbatim would have got the crime to
repel evil with what is better not worse
and god almighty has sent the problem
home the peace be upon him as the last
and final messenger who was a brother to
jesus and moses they all brought the
same message worship the Creator not the
christian do good deeds and we fear
doing any injustice to a human being to
even an animal so now innocent people
that go over to syria they go over to
help
journalists aid workers a Muslim no
Muslim in his right mind who knows this
now can even think about beheading
killing an innocent person because this
is clear if the problem Hamid Allah
calls of God calls him as a mercy to the
world he was sent as a mercy to the
world and God Almighty tells us that he
will not have mercy and those who do not
have mercy to the his creatures on earth
so just as Islam helps me to be more
loving and kind of merciful and I fear
doing any harm to any human being
unjustly so do over 1.7 billion Muslims
all over the world who live a religion
of peace and mercy and justice so Islam
is free of this free of terrorism and
all these other crazy barbaric things
that our people are trying to associate
with it
and we wish that the media would give
the microphone to people who have
condemned these things give the
spotlight to the good that Muslims are
doing but it's shamefully they want to
focus on the 0.111 small fringe elements
nothing to do with Islam